buon pomeriggio
vorrei parlarvi di arte contemporanea
non farò una lezione di storia dell'arte
non sono un critico non sono un
gallerista semplicemente quando posso
vado a vedere delle mostre specie di
arte contemporanea
mi piace guardare i quadri mi piace
vedere anche la faccia della gente di
fronte a questo tipo di quadri
formalmente la faccia e questa mi ci
metto dentro anch'io la faccio sono sono
sono onesto ci troviamo sempre un po in
difficoltà di fronte a un'opera d'arte
moderna non sappiamo mai veramente
quello che l'artista voleva dirci e
quindi si si rompe un po il dialogo
in realtà in un bellissimo libro di
francesco bonami che si chiama questo lo
facevo anch'io
lui dice che per capire l'arte non serve
in realtà essere esperti per capire
l'arte basta avere la mente aperta
sembra facile da fuori dalla galleria
d'arte come si entra dentro e ci si
trova davanti ad un quadro nero gigante
questa la mente aperta si chiude e
quindi il nostro dialogo non va molto a
buon fine
forse perché ci aspettiamo che il quadro
c emozioni deve emozionarci se questa
opera d'arte non ci emoziona non siamo
contenti e usciamo non soddisfatti
vi faccio degli esempi se io fossi un
surfista o avessi vissuto per tanto
tempo al mare e guardarsi questo quadro
sicuramente mi emozioni ray sentirai il
rumore delle onde sentire il profumo
della salsedine insomma suscita in me
alcune mozioni oppure se fossi nato in
olanda un paesaggio come questo
sicuramente risveglierebbe tanti ricordi
della terra di dove sono nato
oppure se fosse un architetto un
geometra un ingegnere un quadro come
questo sicuramente mi metterebbe
tranquillità dico parla il mio
linguaggio mi sento in sintonia con
questo quadro
eppure pensate che questo quadro il
precedente sono dello stesso artista
semplicemente fatti in due periodi
storici diversi
facciamo un altro esempio sono un
tiratore con l'arco eccelso davanti a un
quadro come questo di jasper johns
sicuramente colpirebbe nel segno
vedete come è facile andare a colpire le
emozioni
ognuno emozioni chiunque prova emozioni
anche gli animali e quindi forse l'arte
non ha l'obiettivo di farci provare
emozioni le proveremo comunque proviamo
disgusto proviamo rabbia o proviamo
ammirazione e ovvio è una conseguenza di
guardare un'opera d'arte
quello che forse l'arte dovrebbe fare la
pace deve insegnare ad avere delle idee
l'arte è un idea io spesso lavoro con
l'arte sono un illustratore e dialogo
spesso con l'arte contemporanea ai
maestri del novecento
perché a ogni tanto inseriscono i miei
lavori
alcune alcune opere d'arte e col tempo
ne ho selezionate alcune sette è una mia
piccola galleria personale che che ho in
testa e questi quadri mi hanno col tempo
insegnato qualcosa
ora vi mostrerò questi quadri un breve
racconto è visto che cosa mi hanno
insegnato il primo quadro e questo è una
composizione in rosso blu e giallo di
mondrian un pittore olandese
il padre del neoplasticismo de stijl che
ha fondato in olanda insieme a theo van
doesburg e noi conosciamo mondrian con
queste opere in realtà è un pittore che
ha dipinto tantissimo ha incominciato
con dei paesaggi olandesi quello che
abbiamo visto prima era suo
poi ha fatto un'analisi bellissima sui
mulini a vento
poi sugli alberi poi li ha sintetizzati
sempre di più le semplificati e arrivato
quasi a una nuvola di rami è un certo
punto nel 1920 circa ha detto ok io ho
tutto quello che mi basta una linea
orizzontale una linea verticale il
bianco il nero
i tre colori fondamentali blu rosso e
giallo dal 1920 in poi la sua arte ha
avuto una nuova vita un nuovo respiro è
usato solo questi pochi elementi
addirittura nel 1924 quando l'amico van
der burgh fece un quadro con una
diagonale
la loro amicizia si ruppe immediatamente
perché non hanno la accettavamo andrea
una fronte come questa insomma in questi
quadri ho sempre visto una sorta di
scheletro una sorta di impalcatura come
un palazzo
e alla lunga continuando a guardare le
sue opere mi ha insegnato
questo era l'opera che ha girato per
poter fare pace con collane con l'amico
è segnato questo che i fondamentali sono
fondamentali se conosci le regole del
gioco allora puoi divertirti non può
improvvisare se non è delle basi solide
da cui partire
i fondamentali ti aiutano a cavarsela in
ogni situazione qualsiasi attività ha
dei fondamentali se impari quello hai un
buon valido punto di partenza e mi sono
divertito poi con le opere di monda e
quindi ho provato a interpretarle perché
bisogna provare per capire e mi sono
immaginato mondrian fuori dagli schemi
quindi fuori dalle sue opere e bersi una
birra tranquillo sul tetto mentre fuori
dentro il centro le sue opere il mondo
scorre o però l'ho immaginato fare sport
o suonare a queste musicista nero suona
il blu
fare salto con l'asta può fare il
giardiniere la seconda opera o gruppo di
opere che mi sa tanto tantissimo
influenzato e sono la paura di questo
ragazzo
questo simpatico ragazzo della
pennsylvania si chiama keith haring
arrivo a new york negli anni 80 in
pochissimo tempo divenne uno dei più
importanti artisti della scena pop
newyorkese insieme a warhol maschia e
passava ha passato il primo periodo
della sua vita di quel metropolitana ma
passano tante ore in metropolitana
disegnando questi disegni col gesso
bianco degli spazi pubblicitari invece
tantissimi invece quasi più di 5.000 non
è rimasto quasi neanche uno perché
vengono strappati coperti però ci sono
solo alcune documentazioni fotografiche
come questa e mentre questo ragazzo
disegnavo nella metropolitana della
gente pian piano si fermava e parlava
con lui e lui cominciava a dialogare con
queste persone gli piaceva questo
scambio di informazioni e gli regalava
delle spille con i suoi personaggi
principali il cane il bambino radiante i
ballerini di hip hop e questa gente
camminava per new york si vedeva vedere
da queste spilline e parlava di lui e
diceva ah ok anche tu hai visto quel
ragazzo che disegna quegli strani
geroglifici metropolitana anche le
guardie quando lo catturavano gli
facevano una multa e lo portavano in
commissariato
le multe lui le pagava tutte
regolarmente infatti chiedevano
l'autografo era diventato ormai un
personaggio un personaggio noto aveva
fatto una cosa molto importante
aveva creato una rete e questa cosa mi è
molto rimasta un insegnamento che mi ha
passato i the ring che si parla con
tutti è una raccomandazione semplice che
uno sente da quando è alto così però
quando ti esprimi che esprimi per tutti
non solo per una nicchia tutti devono
riuscire a capire quello che tu dici
proprio perché chi ti sta davanti
completa il tuo messaggio quindi dà
nuova linfa alle cose che una persona
dice ho nel mio caso che un artista un
illustratore fa
e a proposito di questo io come supporto
artistico adoro il manifesto proprio
perché è democratico lo attacchi al muro
chiunque può vederlo
non è per una nicchia mai veramente per
tutti e questa è la copertina di una
mostra che ho realizzato nel 2014 a
cremona che mi ha concesso 40 spazi
pubblicitari in giro per la città ed è
stato veramente un lusso è un onore
essere visti da le persone più distratte
che passavano per la città
e queste sono alcune foto della di
questa esposizione la terza opera
un'opera di alexander calder sono
sculture cinetiche di calder mi piace
tantissimo la sua storia scalderà un
bambino nato in una famiglia di artisti
americana
e poi perché artisti danno sempre un po
convinto a non intraprendere la carriera
di artista perché è precaria perché non
si guadagna molto e quindi l'hanno già
da piccola abituato a costruirsi i
giocatori da solo volevano un bambino
molto autonomo e quindi in ogni casa che
loro visitavano e creavano un piccolo
laboratorio dove lui costruire questi
giocattoli e quindi giocattoli sono un
punto fondamentale perché costruirà
quasi tutta la vita giocattoli non farà
l'artista diventerà un ingegnere
meccanico quindi seguirà i consigli dei
genitori e studierà questa questa
disciplina con tutto questo continuerà a
disegnare un certo punto si troverà a
fare delle illustrazioni per il circo
barnum che era un circo famosissimo in
america e quindi viene a conoscenza del
circo gli piace questo ambiente è molto
colorato e allora mette insieme una cosa
che sapeva fare i giocattoli e il circo
e comincia a costruire un circo fatto di
personaggi di equilibristi di animali
ballerine e lui li muove tutti
ricostruisce rimuove li porta in giro in
una valigia da lì nascerà questo circo
di calder che sarà un vero e proprio
spettacolo
si sposta a parigi il suo circo cresce
diventa di cinque valigie è un vero è
una vera e propria installazione e
davanti al suo atelier c'è la fila di
gente che va a vederlo e ci sono
personaggi del calibro di mirò di man
ray di the champ di mondrian di quello
che abbiamo parlato prima e proprio
mondrian gli parlerà di astrattismo e
allora da quel momento calder fa una
cosa bellissima prende dei fili di ferro
e collega tutte le cose che lui ha
imparato durante la sua vita è
cominciato e ha cominciato a creare
queste sculture e all'anno reso famoso
da ogni volta che guardo un'opera di
calder sospesa a muoversi con l'aria mi
viene in mente questo unisci i puntini
la vera intelligenza è quella di mettere
in relazione le cose che uno sa la vera
capacità e nel mettere in collegamento
le cose che conosci nel momento giusto e
al posto giusto
quella è l'idea geniale
e anche su calder mi sono divertito a
immaginare un calder che bagna una
propria scultura perché alla fine l'arte
da sempre buoni frutti e quindi genera
una mela o questo è un mazzo di carte in
cui si mescolano le carte si scambiano e
ora può diventare la regina è
leggermente spostato forse c'è qualche
esaltato qualcosa nella presentazione
quest'opera è un'opera di deschamps si
chiama el orinatoio fontana ed è colpa
di quest'opera secondo andate in un
museo guardate l'estintore in maniera
strana e non capite se è un'opera d'arte
o se è un arredo del museo
in effetti sì gli piacevano tantissimo
queste cose
immaginate nel 1917 c'è un concorso
arriva questo pezzo a questa commissione
e questo signor matt manda questo
orinatoio girato al contrario
in realtà è deschamps che era nella
giuria sotto mentite spoglie che manda
questo pezzo in maniera molto
provocatoria non viene accettato
ovviamente lui non si arrabbia scrive
una lettera e dice il signor matt ha
scelto questo oggetto gli ha cambiato lo
scopo l'ha messo in un museo e al dato
valore alla sua forma e d'ora in poi voi
entrerete in un museo guarderete questo
cesso in maniera diversa
aveva ragione penso che questo e ancora
adesso in un museo
solamente che è coperto da una teca
perché è già la terza persona che prova
a fargli bp dentro però ha fatto una
cosa molto importante e cioè per fare
qualcosa di nuovo non serve nulla di
nuovo
basta prendere un qualcosa e cambiargli
semplicemente il proprio utilizzo
la vera creazione e trasformare qualcosa
in qualcos'altro
siamo pienissimi di cose nuove che ci
riempiono le case e diventano vecchie
anche in pochissimo tempo reinventare
vuol dire dargli nuova vita a volte la
limitazione può diventare un'opportunità
e questo è un re dimentica mai capita
spesso di fare sulla mia scrivania dove
un temperino diventa una faccia dove una
calla diventa maria callas o dove una
fotocopia sbagliata diventano della
pioggia e degli omini disegnati si
coprono da questa pioggia di parole
un cucchiaino e una bustina diventa un
basso e un amplificatore
questo è il taglio di fontana penso che
tutti lo conoscete non vado nel
dettaglio della critica che c'è intorno
a quest opera è semplicemente su questo
però non c'è nulla da dire o la odi o la
ami ma mi ha insegnato sicuramente una
cosa di passare da questo lo potevo fare
anch'io
a questo l'ho fatto io passate
all'azione partite e fate qualche cosa
non fermatevi alla teoria come diceva
munari chi ascolta dimentica chi vede
ricorda solamente chi fa impara e quindi
ho voluto anch'io rifare un taglio e lo
cucito subito anzi questa è la nonna di
fontana che ovviamente rammendato questo
taglio oppure questo dettaglio su jpeg
per chi si intende un po di computer
forse capisce quest'altro quadro ed è
veramente un quadro di kazimir malevic
quadrato nero
mi sembra chiaro malevic è un pittore
non famosissimo addirittura del suo nome
ci sono sei o sette versioni diverse dei
modi in cui scriverlo e quando fece
questo quadro si racconta che non
mangiano androni per giorni per
l'emozione per lui era un po una pietra
miliare era il momento in cui l'arte si
staccava dalla realtà e dichiarava se
stessa di essere indipendente e lo
faceva con un segno semplice un quadrato
che sembra semplice ma in realtà se
guardiamo con attenzione ovviamente ma
levi non l'ha fatto col righello l'ha
fatto a mano e non è un vero quadrato i
lati non sono perpendicolari tra loro e
poi un'altra cosa strana che nel
quadrato nero di malevic non c'è una
goccia di nero sono tutti colori molto
scuri sovrapposti uno all'altro e quando
guardo questo quadro e l'uso spesso
perché mi attira c'è una cosa che forse
banale che mi ha insegnato però è essere
semplici essere basilari come diceva
bruce lee non è un incremento quotidiano
ma un decremento
la cosa importante è togliere tutto
quello che non serve essere semplici
delle aree diretti
vi aiuterà essere più leggeri più veloci
e più chiari
e qui ho giocato un po col quadrato di
malevich
questo non poteva dimenticare il mio
amore accademico pablo picasso
vediamo sel d'avignon picasso è
assolutamente un maestro a 12 anni
davvero dipingeva come un grande pittore
non poteva partecipare ai concorsi di
pittura quando era bambino perché aveva
una bravura è enorme
il padre pittore quando lo vide
disegnare per le prime volte abbandonò
il mestiere perchè davanti ha un figlio
così non poteva reggere il confronto
picasso disegno per tutta la vita si
contano quasi 30 mila quadri anti 30
mila opere tra quadri sculture incisioni
attraverso tutto il novecento cambiando
mogli come cambiava movimenti artistici
fondò il cubismo passo
all'espressionismo il classicismo il
surrealismo e è una delle cose belle di
picasso che vi sono sempre rimaste
impresse è che quando una cosa ti viene
bene e lui gli venivano particolarmente
bene allora il momento di cambiare
perché la creatività la vera capacità
della creatività non è quella di fare
una cosa bene ma di non farlo uguale due
volte se no diventa metodo quindi
restare coerente con le proprie idee ma
cambiare i punti di vista e picasso li
cambiare i punti di vista
un ultimo messaggio l'arte mi ha
insegnato delle idee e penso che la cosa
principale che deve fare l'arte e ci
chiede di ragionare su quello che
guardiamo e farci venire delle idee
oltre ad emozionarci l'arte ci deve
insegnare ad avere idee solo se abbiamo
idee nostre possiamo dire di essere
veramente liberi grazie
riccardo brosco